bassem bonsoir alors comment se déroule
cette manifestation du dal
mais écoutez samantha la manifestation
vient de prendre fin la délégation qui a
été reçue par le ministère du logement
vient de sortir du ministère un rendez
vous avec le directeur de cabinet une
manifestation qui a été donnée à l'appel
du doigt l appel de certains syndicats
également contre la reprise de ces
expulsions suite à la trêve hivernale
qui avaient été prolongés je vous
rappelle à cause de la crise du
coronavirus et puis contre le mal
logement à paris je suis avec jamel
blanchard un des membres du dal qui a
été reçu par par le ministère du
logement merci de répondre aux questions
intéressant c'est ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ce qui a été dit pendant cette
réunion
ouais on a aperçu un épisode
organisations n'ont pas sans nous et
puis la cgt est un syndicat et notamment
un collectif des sans-papiers
ce qui a été dit ces interrogations qui
sont habituelles un tous les ans
notamment l'acquisition des bâtiments
vides ils vont vite permettre à ce que
plus personne ne soit contre à la rue et
faire en sorte qu'ils aient une vraie
politique en faveur des locataires une
politique humaine ou politiques qu'ils
soient pas dévoués comme on l'a vu par
le confinement qui permettent des
entreprises de pouvoir voir dernier son
loyer mais qu'on pense aussi aux humains
aux êtres humains c'est à dire aux gens
qu'ils celui dit qu ils sont difficiles
comme sociale très difficile et qui
peuvent par le logement faire en sorte
d'avoir enfin une dignité c'est pour 50
menace clairement at war justement sur
les expulsions qui est un arrêt des
expulsions sans relogement et permettre
aussi équine politique de loyer
d'annulation du loyer qui permettent à
chacun de voir s'en sortir est-ce que
vous avez été entendu à ce que les
décisions ont été prises des choses
promises
on verra la suite on n'est pas dupe on a
tellement été plus ou moins écouter
parfois mais jamais réellement entendu
on n'est pas dupe maintenant l'important
c'était de porter porter une parole et
faire en sorte à ce que le gouvernement
puisse se préparer une exclusion sociale
parce que clairement la politique qui
est qui et qui est dévolue actuellement
ne favorise pas justement permettre pas
des gens de pouvoir s'en sortir de
manière dignement et surtout je rappelle
aussi parce qu'on a on passerait avec
les personnes qui sont sans abri je
rappelle que les personnes qui sont
encore la ruée des personnes qui ont été
expulsés pendant l'été c'est juste
inacceptables maintenant ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est que à la question du
logement elle s'entrecroisent avec la
question économique la question de ce
qui ne peut pas vivre dignement on a vu
pendant leur confinement des gens qui
n'ont pas pu aller travailler
on a eu des gens qui sont il se trouve
d'ailleurs on appelait loyer à cause de
ça donc ça sans trop croire avec
d'autres questions c'est pour ça qu'ils
le syndicat cgt qui étaient là qui
veulent organisation si les quartiers
populaires qui étaient présentes c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à plein de questions qui
s'entrecroisent
la question du logement aujourd'hui du
mal logement des sans logis
s'entrecroisent aussi avec la question
des violences policières s'entrecroisent
aussi de la question sociale ma question
économique tout s'entrecroise et c'est
pour ça que en tout cas de nouveux
j'espère que des convergences des
alliances vont se permettre pour pouvoir
finalement essayé d'aborder cette
question là par un autre prisme manière
plus transversale avec quelle politique
qui soit clairement volontaire et non
pas au profit de petits groupes de
petits malins de toute une mafia qui
finalement aujourd'hui profitent
allègrement des financements publics et
s'en sortent s'en sortent finalement
très très bien en tant qu'actionnaire
alors que des gens aujourd'hui dans
l'appui à s'en sortir
vous avez demandé le gel des expulsions
une année blanche est ce que ça a été
entendu par le gouvernement
ça a été entendu par le directeur de
cabinet du ministère du logement j'ai
pas l'impression en tout cas ils ont
noté comme étant entendu j'ai pas
l'impression du tout alors ils ont parlé
de cette circulaire de juillet où
effectivement ils demandaient une
vigilance à ce que au cas par cas et
nous d'ailleurs je suis pas pour la
petite du papa on est pour une politique
solidaire et généraliste maintenant ils
ont indiqué mais dans cette circulaire
ils ont parlé aussi malgré tout favorisé
quand même la fin de compte
comment dire de d'appuyer quand même une
expulsion pour des locataires de
mauvaise foi alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire des locataires de mauvaise foi donc
on retombe bien à chaque fois dans une
dimension un petit peu arbitraire de
définir de qui serait de mauvaise foi ou
qui serait légitime pour être éculé ou
pas bon ben ça c'est pas possible
des gens à la rue contre 1 a rue ce
n'est pas possible surtout quand les
femmes et des enfants
donc il faut revoir ça il faut que la
politique du logement elle soit
clairement une politique qui soit
essentielle ici à cette société et non
pas en 2d tiroirs merci beaucoup merci
dans la provocation
vous l'avez entendu une réunion qui
s'est soldée par des promesses donc les
différents collectifs vont attendre
espère que le gouvernement puisse se
faire quelque chose concernant la
reprise de ces expulsions mais surtout
concernant le mal-logement partout sur
le territoire français était à peu près
1000 à s'être donné rendez vous à paris
dans la capitale pour cette marche en
faveur des mal-logés et surtout en
faveur des expulsés merci beaucoup
bassam chebbi pour toutes ces précisions